hello beautiful people what's up we're
going to be talking about typography
today we're going to be celebrating The
Life and Times of the late and great
Virgil ablo who passed away last year so
I'm scared for myself I'm scared for our
students I wonder how this is all gonna
go I'm not going to fight in the high
enough resolution so I also had to keep
it small enough you know ten thousand
dollars to buy a suitcase just for this
project come on there's almost
commitment here man Jesus Christ kid it
looks like a death notice
so you're doing the right thing which is
in this case the wrong thing and so I I
was sort of sad that that that happened
when Charles mentioned the blur type I'm
like where's the blur type if you're
gonna blur something really blur it
because that's just like a little baby
blur there I just want to say one one
quick editorial note here clip that
video with the audio of Charles saying
that that's a tick tock video 10 points
16 something something Pike of measure
let's make that go viral guys
but we're gonna move over to Charles
Charles take it over who am I doing
first let me read the names here Maggie
let me do Maggie first then yeah I had
one thing to show because uh I had the
product from viksha's okay oh yeah so
you guys see that oh yeah oh yeah so
that was the black uh sort of plastic
cloth that was inspired there but you
know what's interesting even in this
photo is that you can still read the
forms so playing around with the levels
of black you could tell that there's a
person standing in front of a background
but there's space between them and you
can still see the silhouette which is
something you want to be very mindful of
now I hope you're seeing Maggie's piece
what I really liked about this was the
sort of boldness and directness of it I
like the um the commitment to that red
rectangle I like the use of the blur
even though it's artificial to sort of
uh that combined with the translucency
gives it sort of layering and depth I
respond well to the sort of
differentiation of or what I would call
declination but differentiation of sizes
between the largest the medium and the
small type so those are the things that
are really think are going for this
poster I like the off-centered
composition the middle Port part the
breaking boundaries which I consider
that in the arrow I consider the sort of
focal points of the of the composition
that's where I'm going to get meaning
from this composition it seems to get
sort of mixed as a metaphor or
overwrought because there's the breaking
of uh of boundaries in the setting of
the type so the word breaking is halfway
through turns into italic it changes
weight then you also break the word
breaking from the word boundaries and
then the word boundaries gets broken by
the arrow then on top of all that you
get this sort of waterfall of type off
the edge so I think any of the breaking
things like breaking lines breaking
style breaking form are are one kind of
metaphor but the water or fall is
something something else it says it says
falling or it says Cascade or it says
trailing off it has sort of like
different connotations than the idea of
breaking so I I would like to see I
would even though that's a it's a big
part of the sort of uh interest in the
middle of the composition I would like
to see it go away I don't think the
composition would be worse for it and I
think you could really hone in on that
idea of breaking boundaries visually as
a metaphor in addition to the sort of um
the meaning of it I think the uh you
know I talked about at the beginning
under up but ubiquity and deconstruction
you sort of get this uh missed
opportunity to quote Virgil using his
quotes
by using the true quotes So you're doing
the right thing which is in this case
the wrong thing and so I I was sort of
sad that that that happened but I
understand why it happened the Pyramid
of place names down at the bottom just
seems like it's redundant because of the
repetition within it and it's also not
necessary you know it doesn't make any
specific point it doesn't really help
the composition that much so I'd really
like to see those just sort of reduce to
bug tracks or to exist somewhere else
maybe in one of those labels on the on
the right hand side of the composition
finally the the you know there are the
three main ideas of this poster or all
these posters which are ubiquity
deconstruction and breaking boundaries
and we've seen various ways of dealing
with those as um as a sort of Troika as
a sort of triumvirate of themes one is
to sub subvert two of them so that only
one of them has to be paid attention to
which is sort of what you've done here
but that leaves the other two in the
sort of weird this weird Embrace with
one another so I wonder if it's some
point in any or all of these whether
those things get into conversation with
one another or we find a way to
rationally push them aside maybe it
again is one of those things where you
take them and put them in a label on the
right hand side that said if they're
going to all three be there they should
be in some kind of conversation with one
another the last thing there's an
artificiality to the to the layering
that I mentioned at the top that I would
really love to see resolve like if this
escaped computer land and got into the
physical world when you started actually
playing with true layering and
transparency and then photographing it I
think you'd get a much more sort of
material sort of tactile feel to this
that ultimately would draw people in in
a really in a really sort of magnetic
Way by and large I I like what I'm
seeing here you know one thing I like
about this is kind of the difference
between the Splashy centerpiece here and
then the little organized squares on the
side which feel like uh like stickers or
packaging or a label on the side of a
piece of of artwork so I kind of like
the contrast between those two those two
Styles but I I agree with Charles that I
think like there's too many changes with
that kind of headline in the Middle with
like um with it yeah changing weight and
getting cut and and kind of spilling
over it's just a little it's a little
bit too much but I do like the variety
of scale and kind of treatments you're
using across I think the the challenge
with taking on a project like this when
you look at the Virgil's body of work
you can see that there is
um a playfulness but also a restraint to
what is and isn't done and I think it's
that tension that lives between these
two things that makes those designs so
iconic and then we as designers and
topographers we try to do that and we
don't fully quite understand so
oftentimes We'll add so many different
elements and it just seems like they're
all fighting against each other what I
think is most accessible in this
composition is just the the the Bold Red
Box the arrow and then maybe some of the
the off-white symbol that the the
four-pointed cross and and then and then
just let everything else be subservient
to this and just play around with this
there's some wonderful opportunities
here for you to really again play with
materials uh printing out things on
labels adding them back on you could
easily take black gaffing tape and and
make that Arrow out of black Gaff tape
so there's a there's a there's a texture
and a tactile kind of quality and when
you just look at it because those are
themes that Virgil explored when Charles
mentioned the blur type I'm like where's
the blur type if you're gonna blur
something really blur it because that's
just like a little baby blur there push
it a little bit so that we can see even
if it's artificial at least the law of
contrast still applies here uh I I think
the ubiquity at the top it looks like a
little piece of tape and I would have
loved to explore that so that it's used
for something other than just being at
the top one thing that you'll also find
that in in design when you put an
element on on a page or poster you you
have to make it feel like it's part of a
larger design concept and so if you have
something at the top oftentimes if
you're able to repeat that Dimension
somewhere else on the page align it to
maybe the middle third of the page
itself then we start to feel like oh
these are not just people having
separate parties but this is one really
big party and because you can set type
in so many different ways you have to
ask yourself when I when I step away
from how
the tool allows me to work and I try to
do these things like the cascading type
why am I doing that and is it one too
many tricks and that's the problem it's
like whenever you watch cooking shows
it's usually get really great
ingredients do it the way people expect
and then make one twist one unexpected
break from it and that's usually
wonderful oftentimes what what on these
cooking shows what they do is they're
like well let's with a little bit of
truffle is good let's add a lot of
truffle and it just becomes overpowering
it's just too much of a good thing okay
Maggie I think you've done these
critiques with us before right I think I
recognize your name or maybe I'm in the
Pro Group oh you're in the program
that's how I know your name okay
all right thank you very much Maggie uh
do you have any questions for us or any
comments all of your comments were
really spot on I was really struggling
when I do this piece and my mind is
going like monkey bananas so
I got totally overwhelmed and let me
tell you why I got overwhelmed because I
got hang up most of the time I was
analyzing the information hierarchy I
thought there was so much information
that I cannot tell a coherent story with
it I researched virtual Avalos life and
story because I wasn't very familiar
with him I want to understand the text
between all of these uh the relationship
between all of these texts so I know
which two belong to the same hierarchy
which one should be the higher one and
then I should decide like what is the
central message or story I want to tell
initially I thought that's going to be
Virgil abelo's life then there's a
variety of things and off-white and LV
image such as like two of the biggest
brand that he worked with and then
there's ubiquity and deconstruction
where do I put that are those tag lines
so I had probably in my mind like
putting all of these on the page and
still make them fall into the right
hierarchy and tell a coherent story
that's when I got so many ideas maybe
this one should be dominant maybe this
one is supporting it to this one So
eventually I just mess up myself and I I
wasn't satisfied with the piece but I
was so in need of help so I I'm very
appreciative of all the feedback that
you give me I do like that about
critiques is that they they they're not
the it's not the end of the process a
critique is the beginning of the next
part of the process the conversation and
what you just told us sort of lead me to
believe that if I was able to check in
with you in two weeks this would be uh
really dramatically improved poster yeah
I would also like to hear from either of
you if at the end we have time how you
analyze the text and what you would put
as the information hierarchy not the
design element but just help us analyze
and understand it well let's do it right
now
um uh Charles how do you when you're
looking at a block of copy how do you
begin what's your process like how do
you prioritize one thing over something
else a trick that I would play on myself
that I in turn played on my students
which was to say if you don't understand
what the information is trying to tell
you then remove all formatting from it
so set it 10 and a half on 16 point
flush left rag right on a 20 Pica
measure and read it in the order that
it's set in just helvetica you know
helvetica regular like is vanilla as you
could possibly make it and then read it
and read it again until it tells you
whether it's out of order or whether
it's it's um you know whether it's in
the proper order and if it's in the
proper order then can you start to
insert line spaces in between the groups
of information in order to understand
how the grouping should work and again
all of this you could do with the
typewriter but nobody use this type
writers anymore so I've sort of resorted
to 10 and a half on 16 point flush left
right right helvetica on a 20 Pica
measure just because that's all you ever
really need to sort of understand what
the information wants to tell you once
you're there if it doesn't ask for
anything else then you don't do anything
else that's the you've deconstructed it
you've reduced it to its basic form and
if it doesn't ask for anything more then
it's not going to get it chances are
something in that in that reading will
tell you that it needs something more
that's our job so how do the line breaks
work how does spacing work what's the
punctuation like all of those are
crucial pieces of information before you
begin the design process I just want to
say one one quick editorial note here
Mark and Jonah I think that clipped that
video with the audio of Charles saying
that that's a tick tock video ten points
16 something something Pike of measure
just repeat that over and over again
let's make that go viral guys okay back
over you Terence I was just gonna add
you know try Charles used to be a book
designer so he is an expert at you know
slicing up information into into a table
of contents so if you if you think about
yeah if you think about the information
that way
um you know if you had to present it in
in a magazine form or a book form uh
what's the What's the title of the
chapter uh what's this what's the
subhead so yeah and I mean it kind of
goes back to the idea I mean the ideas
that informed Virgil's work which is
semantics construction deconstruction
context all these things are really
important to us as graphic designers and
they're crucial they were crucial to me
in my my Beginnings as a designer and
again back to George sadek my chocolate
Slovakian Mentor he would say Jesus
Christ kid just read the [ __ ] text
it was like all the answers for what it
wants to be are in there you just have
to read it and listen that's guided me
for all of my career there was a lot of
reference to Jesus is Christ from your
former body
yeah sorry it's very uh he was he was
not very reverential
um and he had he cursed like a truck
driver
um but that his uh turns a phrase
including his profanity are are very
much locked in with my memory of him so
I'm I apologize I'm channeling him I'm
not speaking as myself I don't of course
take the lord's name
so Maggie one of the things that you you
could probably do when you're reading a
block of texts is is first of all do
nothing to it but when something speaks
to you celebrate that part and just
choose one thing it could just be the
word ubiquity and riffing on that theme
like what does ubiquity mean or breaking
boundaries or just the date like maybe
making the date really important saying
he lived a very short and very
productive and creative life and and
it's it's short but it's it's very sweet
and Powerful you just pick one thing to
celebrate and then let that be the theme
like it's like when you're directing a
movie or something you have to find the
spine of the story and then everything
else has to serve that otherwise it's a
distraction let's move on to the next
person now notice something you see we
talked about this before traditionally
speaking the emblems of the shoe live
flat on the shoe itself and you can see
here because they're not fastened down
and then they take their own shape and
they cast a shadow so easily if if you
all just try to print things out on
vinyl or different construction paper
and it didn't make everything so perfect
it creates its own life and there's just
something very magnetic that draws your
eye and he's kind of bringing the the
process of a collage to something that
to a material that isn't collaged yeah
like a shoe oh good good observation
they're nice the thing that I like about
this the most it's the plastic bag it's
the materiality of that plastic bag and
what it the potential of it for
containing the entire poster and sort of
elevating as Virgil did in in some of
his pieces this idea of things in
plastic bags as as a sought after object
and it's really something that that I
think we know on this end of the
consumer spectrum that people on the
luxury end of the consumer Spectrum were
just grasping as a result of his work
which is that there is this the this
thin film of plastic actually creates
value when you put something in that
despite the fact that it's plastic it
creates this sort of sense of
specialness about something that it
needs to be protected and I would love
to see that play a little bit more in
this composition now that said there is
way way too much going on in this
composition one of the things that that
plastic bag and this this centrality and
very Frank uh ubiquity with the proper
improper quotes the size and
distribution of the place names I find
that all just great of a piece like sort
of you know spread around random but at
the same time really pleasing now I'm
going to do something to this
composition which I felt in my in
looking at it made it a thousand times
better which is just to remove the now
I've removed the plastic bag which I was
just telling you how much I loved now I
am deeply in love with this composition
uh though it flows like I mean there are
some things that need to be fixed like
why have these things play off each
other in this sort of very boring
diagonal relationship they could just as
easily drift into other parts of the
margin look at the way that the
hierarchy is established without that
background and look at the way that the
that those place names which seem so
anchored artificially on the edges of
those tears and I'll bring it back so
you can see it now exists like leaves
falling from a tree or like you know a
leaf in a in a brook that's that's
flowing there's a poetry and a sort of
beautiful Randomness and a sort of
natural quality to the way that they sit
on the page it seems very anchored at
the bottom left with Virgil and that's
the way it should be that's the place in
the composition that your eye comes to
rest and that's where he is I don't have
much more to say about this than than
that taking away is probably the thing
that I would do most of these pieces I
would say that the Bull's imagery in the
background is competing with with
everything else and it's not adding to
the composition so I just like to see it
would be my first take away take this
away yeah editing easiest way to find
strength in a composition that you feel
like you've finished like what happens
if you kill Your Darlings what happens
if you get rid of the things that you
hold dear that you felt were the anchors
in the composition what are you left
with and is it better than the thing
that you thought you loved it's forcing
us as viewers as creators rather to look
at the composition like a like a viewer
would look at it that is to say to look
at it as a finished thing and then you
yourself decide how you can make it
better and usually that to me involves
taking stuff away I like this now
without the background yeah and and I
think my you know in in my experience
that the tip with editing is it just
takes time you can't edit your thing as
soon as you're finished doing it you
have to wait till tomorrow to do the
editing and um in order for for it to
just sit for a minute
um so I think that would be yeah yeah
sometimes you have to let up on the gas
like I find that I my breakthroughs come
at four in the morning when I'm in REM
sleep mode or in the shower when I'm you
know just concentrating on the feeling
of how how good warm water is running
through my hair like those are the
moments when you're able to you you
can't be at the work you can't be
consciously sort of like trying to
hammer away at a problem that then
suddenly the the sky is open or the
scales are lifted or whatever other
metaphor I think when you turned off all
those layers I I'm missing the the the
plastic part which I thought was so
special and also the the hit of red and
some of the halftone low low res images
that were in there but when you took it
away I was able to kind of breathe I
kind of my eye knew where to look and
and now I could appreciate the the
texture and the typeset that you're
playing around with here one one thing
that I would generally advise people to
to avoid is to take type and just Jam
them into the corners it feels not as
intentional as it could and you're not
utilizing the space if you look at the
1980 to 2021 and Virgil himself they're
all just push the corner and it and then
it's like very centered in terms of its
layout with the U the word ubiquity
there I think there's some wonderful
things that you can do as Charles is
playing around with this to kind of show
you what else can be done here in terms
of how you play around with a type and
let's see where this this leads to but
there are some really beautiful elements
in here the texture that exists behind
the word virtual hablo and and Tokyo is
really cool to me there's something that
that feels very organic about that where
are you taking us on this Charles I'm
just getting him out of the corners I
mean okay yeah like you know you know
take that take that coffee table and
move it to the center of the room yeah
there's a lot that you can do there so
what what I would suggest that you do is
how do you bring in a little bit of the
color uh in in the the plastic without
it being just so overwhelming for us to
look at yeah I would love to bring that
plastic bag back into it somehow there
was one other thing and you're in a car
I'm jealous
all right honestly right now I don't
know how my com I don't know I can't see
myself or anything but let me tell you
something right now I how do you say
that four in the morning I definitely
was at four in the morning trying to
figure this out did my research like
Megan did it was like literally going
through podcasts literally like trying
to understand like what I was creating
so that it made sense not only to me but
as like a designer the people who are
going to view this and um fun fact
because I was understanding that this
was to be considered globally I placed
all the countries the United States
Paris as if they would be on the map in
that aspect so it kind of like Loops you
around oh neat thanks so it's like uh
like how it would be laid out on a on a
map right like yeah geographically like
in in its location relative to each
other yeah correct correct so what was
kind of like random and playful is
actually there's a layer of thought and
intentionality behind that I will admit
this uh Chris I was I was reading the
the project parameters and something
that stood out to me when you were I
think it was the the video the critique
video that you had messaged or that you
had done with um someone previously
about this experimental typography one
thing that you said to me that stack was
like if you want to be comfortable
that's fine stay in your lane like all
of us will just kind of like keep moving
forward I was like oh man like I've
never done this before but I was like
okay let's go crazy let's do it
yes when you're driving stay in your
lane otherwise get out of your lane
so we'll link it all together okay
wonderful all right I think it's time to
to move on to our last person from
Charles Group which is Kevin so Kevin's
piece I like a lot about it it's very
sort of Frank again with Virgil's name
just saying it big and loud I'd like the
formal contrast as as Terence pointed
out in the earlier piece between the
word ubiquity and everything else on the
page I think that's fantastic I even
respond to the oversized shoelaces as a
three-dimensional object but then
there's so much so much going on besides
those three big things that I like the
shape of the sneaker being outlined by
the by the type I have a question while
we're going through this I noticed that
now a lot of the software on my
Macintosh allows us to use Smart quotes
by default but how do you go in and use
primarks or double Prime marks that's a
great question because it does come up
first you could turn off within the
preferences you can go in and turn off
Smart quotes which seems
counterintuitive and again it's Global
so it's probably not what you want to do
but you can go into the type palette or
to type menu and choose glyphs and then
you'll be able to find the actual
primarks instead of the quote marks and
you can insert them manually by double
clicking on them in the glyphs palette I
see yeah Adobe Adobe calls them uh
typographers quotes
So at the risk of you know pulling again
killing all of the things that you love
about this composition Kevin or all the
things that you baked into it you know
it's the one too many notes hair Mozart
kind of thing like maybe taking away
three or four of the things that are
happening within the composition and
concentrating on the things that are
um you know that are that are most
successful like the you know the share
the share share Shear scale of this type
the beauty of this sort of formal
contrast uh this I find a little bit
that could be shrunk down to something
smaller oops I'm destroying the
composition through this but basically
basically you know getting away from
these sort of larger lockups and I'll
undo all this stuff so you can see I
want a lot less in this and so I keep
taking Pieces away from it and trying to
figure out which of the things that
you're doing here I like the most is it
the stripes is it the large shoelaces is
it um it's definitely not the shape of
the shoe outlined by the the letters
that I would I can tell you
categorically is my least favorite part
of the Composites composition but
there's so much else going on in here
that there's no need to sort of to sort
of pick and choose so yeah I I really
want
um well and I'll point out this you
already had too many words to deal with
so this is the opposite of if we go back
to the um to the piece with the stripes
in the black frame this is the opposite
of that you're adding more things into
the composition that you don't need you
concentrate on grappling with the things
that are already there and make them
work perfectly and then if at the end it
says I need something else give it
something else but don't otherwise like
leave that off the table the one thing
that I wanted to point out in this as a
sort of as a key takeaway these pieces
that are mock-ups and details like this
one in particular this is a better
composition than the composition this is
more Virgil ablo than the poster itself
is what I'm saying is that the frame the
space surrounding it and the context in
which this appears which you've created
in this particular composition is more
powerful than the composition that you
created you've added the walls you've
taken your poster as a Virgil would have
taken something else and put it in a new
context and given it power so it's
almost forgiving a thousand sins by
giving it the proper context does that
carry do you understand what I'm saying
yeah I'm sorry um no first of all thank
you so much for you know picking the
graphic to be critiqued
um yeah definitely I did have some
issues like trying to come up with
something that was you know kind of
minimal and clean but at the same time
something that had a lot of information
and something that you know people would
kind of stare for for some time time to
kind of break down you know the
reasoning behind all of the different
elements and so you know I uh there was
what this like um Jordan Air sneaker
that I really liked and the thing is I
was kind of questioning to myself how
can I break down the elements of the
sneaker into a poster because I
understand that part of the brief was
that it was going to be showcased like
right next to the piece so I was like I
want to make sure the poster has the
elements of the sneaker but at the same
time it doesn't have like a little photo
like a photograph of um of the sneaker
but instead just gonna have the main
elements so for example here what I kind
of wanted to use was the color of the
lasers which was you know part of the
composition or the shape the outline of
the sneaker uh and even I was kind of
thinking why do I want to use red just
besides the fact that the Snicker is red
but I also thought that you know the the
name of the countries have their flags
have red as a common color that was like
I want to use that part of you know the
common element in the flags of these
different countries racing kind of
represented the overall composition but
yeah what you're saying makes total
sense to me Kevin I want to climb inside
of your head and I mean just lean closer
to the microphone rather than trying to
pry open your ear and walk in it is any
of those things any one of them is right
like any one of them is some lever for
creativity but all of them together are
not serving you and they're not serving
your viewers they're not serving anyone
let all the voices shout but then listen
to the loudest one and really serve it
like don't don't water it down by by
introducing another concept on top of it
because they will fight with one another
and nobody wins so when I looked at the
Paris China Tokyo Japan United States
that little lock up I thought oh those
are some that's cool if that was the
only thing in the composition if that
was a composition unto itself and that's
what the poster was about that would be
awesome but layered on top of the shape
of the outline of the shoe and
everything else that's going on in the
composition I just wanted to scream at
the poster not at you give me one thing
give me one moment where I can sort of I
can sort of bask in the meaning of this
poster but I kept being pulled in
different directions you're darling in
this case the thing that you love most
the shape of that shoe is the thing that
you need to kill in this composition
it's what you've got to get rid of it's
um and I'm saying that as I'm your new
type friend I'm saying that as you're as
a concerned citizen or whatever you want
me to be but somebody who genuinely you
know sympathetically cares for your for
your progress it's what you gotta do
it's you just gotta let go of it but
something in what you said
um really resonated which is that the
shape of the shoe and the composition of
the shoe the form of the shoe all of
that really you know was something that
that motivated you that appeals to you
and I would love to see that not into
creating the shoe over again out of type
but to look at the shoe itself like
Terence said we've all got we've all got
phones and access to practically every
photograph that was ever photographed in
the history of the world so you know
give me the shoe show me the shoe find a
new way of using it deconstruct it
flatten it make it into a plan do
something with it but you know do be
Virgil with it be bold give it a new
context Charles when you were turning
off layers I thought the design got
better with each layer that you turned
off which is an exercise you all can do
when you get that tunnel vision or as
Maggie had like monkey brain tell monkey
brain to be quiet for a little bit as
you as the adult in the room just turn
off layers and first when you pick this
design Charles I'm like oh my God what
is he gonna do with this one and just
simply allowing the shoelaces which I
really like once you turn off all this
extra stuff how it wraps around the top
and continues through it makes it feel
much more dimensional I think it's a
really good thing that you're doing
having really big bold type like the
virtual the way you've typeset it that
also looks really good just because you
can put type on a path does it mean that
you should and generally speaking you
probably should never just generally
speaking right you can work around all
these things and and keep in mind this
thing that if this is part of a
traveling exhibition we're gonna have
the shoe to look at in front of us so
showing me the shoe again in the exact
same way or the silhouette doesn't do a
lot we have to do something else so
think about it we we complement what is
there we don't mirror it you're not
trying to do the the shoe the poster
version of the same shoe you just draw
apart some things that you like and you
highlight that and it allows us to
really appreciate the shoe even more and
that that's the part I'm coming from so
one of the things that you can do as you
are all battling this when you have so
many elements reduce the variables use
one typeface use fewer Point sizes use
one weight and here we've got like a lot
of different things going on we got a
capsule looking shape that surrounds the
address and it's just and we're using a
bold typeface with maybe a thinner light
it's just so many different things and
if you were just take some of these
things and scale them down 70 80 percent
it gives the rest of the the posters
room to breathe and free eye to navigate
around so it doesn't feel like you're
just jamming everything into one part
but look how much more powerful this
poster is now this looks like a really
cool hang tag or or a gigantic Banner
you can do a lot with this it's just
because it's much simpler to work with
Okay so whenever you're confused turn
off layers simplify the design choices
that you're making and just leave it it
kind of grouped together as a block of
information and and then explore within
that I think an opportunity here could
have been to to maybe have this type set
like embroidered so Virgil ablo is you
can see the stitching and that would be
amazing and do something with that so
that's your one element of
dimensionality besides the shoelace I
think that would have been really dope
for you to do pause here Terence yeah
similar I think you got you guys covered
it all and and kind of creating more
negative space for this one you know
helps and again with the with the shoe
is like the shoelace already says shoe
and then the outline of the shoe says
shoe again so it's um yeah it's
repeating and I like kind of the the
subtleness of the shoelace without the
image of the shoe is much more
sophisticated way of communicating that
so I think those are all good and it
reminds me of my design education when
um I had a you know teacher asked me to
do a hundred thumbnail sketches of what
a business card was going to be before
touching a computer and and I think
that's um what we've we've seen a couple
of posters today that are kind of
overlapping too many ideas into one
thing and I think if you if you were to
force yourself to draw a hundred
thumbnails on on paper it would get
easier to separate those ideas as to
have kind of one one per thumbnail in
that way so that could be another
exercise you could try at home too yeah
and as a as a fellow teacher at Parsons
used to say I always have to remind the
students that the thumbnails are road
maps they are maps to what the final
piece will look like it's just a matter
of choosing through them but a lot of
them will do 100 sketches and then put
the sketches away and come and do do the
composition and not pay attention to the
thing that they actually made that has
the power it will take you there I want
to just highlight one thing and ask you
ask you two questions that are coming in
from the chat here Charles you were
talking about take the shoe flatten out
deconstructed do something with it you
could Kevin you wouldn't probably want
to do this with the pair of whites now
you can you can get a used pair of
Jordans and take some materials and
break it apart take the sole apart
deconstruct the eyelets the laces and
lay them flat sandwich them down and
just do something with that that would
be wonderful that way it's complementing
the design versus just mirroring it now
here's the question I think you already
answered this question this one comes
from Stephanie Anderson where do you
teach Charles right here right now
you're in it right now yeah I know I
taught for a long time I thought for two
decades at Parsons
um and when I started working at
monotype coincided with the birth of my
son and later the birth of my daughter
and so the time that I have to actually
dedicate to teaching has been decidedly
curtailed but I love opportunities like
this and working with our our clients to
sort of to offer what I can to sort of
Help The Help The Graphic conversation
along and uh if if you know there's
there's a parallel here if you're a fan
of Project Runway I think Charles was
like like the Tim gun of design like
he's dropping terms and people are like
what did he say again we'll have to
listen back to this and then use a
dictionary and just follow along
everybody that's funny Tim Gunn uh he
interviewed me for uh Parsons oh he did
yeah look at that yeah okay so assistant
Dean at that point yeah okay here's the
question coming in from David Koh yeah
David Co is asking this question I'm
drawn to Charles's mention of killing
Your Darlings the ideas or details that
we get emotionally attached to how do
you tell when you're making Darlings out
of the ideas or elements and how do you
prepare make yourself Kill Your Darlings
in order to move forward in that work
great question by the way David usually
it's somebody saying you've got to get
rid of that
because I tell you Your Darlings are so
close to you it's often difficult to see
them yourself as as your pets and again
all of this is It's morbid but the idea
is that these things grow so close to
you that you can't imagine life without
them until somebody says you should
really let go of that somebody like uh
Charles comes along who's your new type
BFF tells you you know get rid of it
then it's time it's like flipping a coin
like heads or tails and then you flip it
and it comes up heads and you're like
you just ask ask yourself how you feel
about it once you got rid of it uh you
know once you have to contemplate
getting rid of it I love the coin
flipping because when if you're
disappointed by what the coin shows you
either way the coin lands it reveals
what your true feelings are about it but
and I think we're also bumping into this
this area of like uh ART versus design
and if if you are creating art and it's
only for yourself that's your darling
and if you are creating a piece of
design that is intended for to serve
someone else that is that's where
holding on to the darling can can be
risky because it's uh it's too personal
um so I think that's that's kind of
attention and maybe even if you're a
fine artist and you're you're working by
yourself and you have all these Darlings
and then you get to a gallery right and
the
um you know the the curator at the
gallery says this piece is stronger than
this one I think we should keep that one
in the back you know so there's yeah
there life is full of editing I suppose
yeah